so we're continuing to fight
disinformation about vaccines and it's
it's really becoming a game of
whack-a-mole at this point vaccination
is the way out of the pandemic we are
seeing a rapid rise in cases cases up 69
in the united states since the uh bottom
uh a few weeks ago told you about that
yesterday or the day before and one
thing that really makes me sick of the
coveted vaccine conspiracies is that
some of them so obviously don't make
sense and yet they keep getting repeated
they become
memetic and viral
the vaccine has metal and it magnetizes
you that was going around for a while in
fact
i told the story of my lyft driver in
miami i got to miami for a vacation a
couple weeks ago get into a car masked
of course i was wearing 12 masks and a
helmet and the lyft driver says oh no no
no i'm not getting vaccinated because my
mom got the second dose and then her
whole body became magnetized
that's one another one is the vaccine
modifies your dna it's called an mrna
vaccine you inject it and then your dna
becomes modified it's almost like you
become some kind of hybrid being
the vaccine can give you the virus is
another one that was earlier on and one
that's been floating around for a little
bit now is that simply being around
vaccinated people could do things to you
and the term that they've come up with
is shedding vaccine
sort of an analogous term to the concept
of shedding virus particles when you're
sick
here's one example this is deanna
lorraine deanna lorraine is a republican
conspiracy theorist who ran for
california's 12th congressional district
last year lost the primary she's
explaining to some guy i don't even know
who this is
about how she was around vaccinated
people
and uh her period got all messed up take
a listen to this when i took a little
trip last month i was telling you about
with a couple of my liberal
friends last uh last month for a weekend
we were in close quarters
i uh they had all been vaccinated and
i'm the only one that hadn't been
vaccinated already a red flag right okay
good and it's a mistake that i'll never
make again in my i wish she was saying
the mistake was not being vaccinated but
that's not where she's going with this
life but i missed my period and yeah
again sorry earmuffs but i missed my
period and i haven't received it since
i'm freaking out a little bit i'm scared
because could i be infertile now so the
first question is if you're that freaked
out don't you call a doctor right like
why are you reporting it to
stu peters maybe is this guy's name um
haven't you all why wouldn't you already
have asked your doctor about it vaccine
shedding is real it's causing lots of
different side effects including missed
periods in women infertility early
menopause and women in their 30s and now
i've experienced it firsthand and i need
to protect myself i'm no longer going to
be around vaccinated women
because i need to care about my
fertility and i can you imagine so
there's a couple there's a few things
there first of all
where to even start so um no no evidence
of early menopause related to the
vaccine
no evidence of infertility related to
the vaccine but there's really two parts
here first is
the vaccine causing missed periods
if you get the vaccine
versus whether you could miss a period
from being near someone who has been
vaccinated let's do the latter first
there is no way to be affected by people
around you being vaccinated other than
you will be less likely to get the virus
and you will be less likely to end up in
the hospital and you will be less likely
to die thanks to people around you being
vaccinated if you were sick with covid
your body can release virus particles as
you cough etc so you can be if you're
sick you can be shedding the virus
that's true
unless you are vaccinated with a vaccine
that contains live virus which the covid
vaccines do not
your body can't shed
vaccine particles or virus particles
whatever it is that you call them
there's no physiological mechanism for
it to happen with the vaccines that are
being used in the united states um
vincent vendito who's an assistant
professor of pharmaceutical sciences
says quote it is possible to have viral
shedding after a vaccine but that
requires a vaccine with a
live virus to be used as the basis for
the vaccine that is not the basis of the
covet vaccines used in the united states
the only way for this to potentially
happen is to have a live attenuated
vaccine it has a weakened version of the
germ that causes the disease none of our
coveted vaccines in the u.s do that with
the live virus now in terms of vaccines
affecting the periods of women who get
vaccinated
women's periods and the immune system
are very very much connected as a woman
is about to ovulate her immune system
ramps itself up to prevent any
infectious agents from maybe interfering
with the fertilization and implantation
of an egg so that you can successfully
start a pregnancy this is like
reproductive science once the egg is
fertilized and implants
the immune system dampens to accept the
pregnancy the uterus has immune cells
those can be affected by hormonal
changes the immune system and cortisol
the stress hormone are related and
periods respond very strongly to
cortisol levels so the long and short of
that is it's being studied
there are anecdotal reports of a late
period after the second dose in some
women we don't yet know whether it's
related to the vaccine it's conceivable
that the vaccine might impact one or two
period the timing of one or two periods
following the second dose
because your immune system is hard at
work developing immunity to the virus
and or due to the elevated cortisol
levels there's no evidence of an impact
on fertility there's no evidence of a
long-term effect and remember this woman
wasn't even vaccinated herself she's
claiming just by being near vaccinated
people
she believes her menstruation was
affected so this is really wild stuff
and these are sticky ideas that are not
going away